item number 51 on the checklist are you
creating a new market or servicing an
existing one and how to tell the
difference
so i believe that some of the great
brands
induce a market to exist they create a
new behavior in the world so if we look
at something like uh spotify and com
just you know i'm an investor in com
obviously but uh not an investor but do
love spotify you know people were
listening to music before spotify came
along in fact you know people had real
networks or they had cd collections
amazon music there were a lot of
different music providers out there uh
and people were using itunes to buy by
the track consumers love music we know
that so was spotify creating a new
behavior listening to music
no
maybe you could argue creating playlists
was a new behavior but spotify
figured out the rights issues they
removed a lot of friction from an
existing market
music listening was an existing market
so they were going to compete with that
existing market that means they were
going to go head-to-head with people
buying
individual tracks on itunes which of
course was competing against cds before
it so that was
the way the markets sort of played out
in music you had cds which were printing
money for the industry then you had
single tracks buying you know particular
songs on itunes for 99 cents that was a
bit of a disaster for the music industry
because you know people went from
spending 12 to 15 bucks on a cd to just
you know sniping the top two tracks that
they wanted to listen to over and over
again
and artists hated it now you go back to
spotify massive consumption
you know and arguably people are
listening to more music than they ever
had
now for com
what was the market for a meditation app
before com existed uh and headspace
their competitor there really was no
market for it meditation was this weird
thing you did if you
lived in santa monica and like some
churches and basements or rec centers or
a yoga studio on the weekends might have
one or two meditation classes or there
were
you know five thousand dollar
you know courses you could take it
wasn't something that was in the general
perception of the public
and
sure you could find on
youtube or you know itunes education had
some select mp3s here or there you could
go find but there wasn't a netflix
a subscription spotify of meditation so
they basically created the category
people didn't know they needed it they
got it they had more equanimity reduced
anxiety reduced depression more focus
more joy in their life and then they
added sleep and people got to sleep
better you know all the great things
that com and their contemporaries did so
they induced a new market
i would argue that uh if you look at
uber airbnb they also induced markets
airbnb i remember in the early days i've
told the story before i had one of the
producers on the show say they were
going to japan and i was like oh wow you
know i know the producer was getting
paid back then it wasn't a lot of money
i was like wow japan's super expensive
like i have to plan my trip there and
think about what i'm going to spend and
she's like yeah i got a you know a room
in kyoto for 40 bucks a night and i'm
gonna go there for the first six nights
and then i was like sorry forty dollars
like that's what you spend on lunch and
she's like oh no it includes breakfast
and i was like okay wow
airbnb i believe
yes it competed with hotels but hotels
continued to do well so i think what
they did is induced people to take
longer trips more trips and maybe uh
trips they wouldn't otherwise have taken
so i think it did both and clearly
the numbers show that the only people
who really i think lost out with airbnb
were the two-star three-star hotels in
other words the really cheap hotels that
weren't a great experience
and you're like i don't really want to
stay at this hotel it's like 89
or 125 i remember staying at those with
brian alvey back when i was broke and
we're trying to get things going and i
was 20k in debt with web blogs inc and
we would literally get whatever the
cheapest place was you know 99 bucks in
a city and we'd get a double room and
the two of us would stay in the room uh
together because we couldn't afford two
rooms you know it's 99 bucks it's big
money so airbnb then became an option
shortly after that and obviously uber
people started taking more rides they
would go out more often so in la we saw
this people wouldn't go out to dinner or
drinking because they didn't want to
drive drunk so there was a lot of you
know stay-at-home culture i think it did
induce more people to go out uh during
that time free endeavor okay
item number 52 on the checklist let's
see if you can check this one off do you
understand the difference between what i
call a lazy tam and a bottom up to him
so tam stands for total addressable
market
and early stage investors
are not generally making a decision on
tam they're usually making a decision
you know i'm talking about angel
investors
based upon the product the team and
maybe some early customer traction
however uh when you get to later rounds
of funding yeah tam does come into play
because people want to know how big can
this be because you're charging you know
10 20 30 40 million dollars
for the valuation of a company which
means people are spending three to 10
million dollars to own 20 of it these
vcs are going to want to understand the
total addressable market well there's a
lazy way to do this which you type in
like what is the market for it and you
know you find some number from gartner
it's 4.4 trillion in 2022.
well
what does that include well that number
is going to include everything like
buying computers software monitors you
know consultants it's a giant number you
didn't create that number now
what would be better is if you were
going to make something very specific
you were making a new uh webcam is it
and the total addressable market for it
comparable to the market for webcams
no and then if you include in webcams
like everybody who has a webcam which is
every phone
and you're like there's five billion
webcams out there that's not your market
either you're not if you're making a
fancy
you know state-of-the-art uh webcam that
people would use as a replacement for
the one built into their laptop
that's a different market you have a
very specific group of people like
creators uh so then you might work on a
bottom up tam
you might say hey who are people who are
professionally creating video how many
creators are there on youtube with over
10 000 followers how many uh creators on
tick tock have over 25 thousand
followers those might be the people who
will be inclined to be in your bottom up
market
and so you really want to understand the
tam let's take another look at a lazy
tam example you know you have acme
corporation they're selling staff
software at the dentist's office they
charge a thousand dollars per month per
office okay great here's a lazy tab
according to the american dental
association from june 2020 the total
projected dental spending for 2021 was
between 123 billion and 154 billion lazy
tm would you just take that number and
put it in there oh you know this is what
dentists spend on equipment
that's not your tam if you're making sas
software for them to manage their office
you're not going to get 10 of that
market of and have a 15 billion revenue
company in
dentist office you would want to know
well who are you selling to what type of
dentist office so well it turns out in
2020 there were 201 000 working dentists
in the u.s according to the ada okay so
now you got a more interesting number
okay if they each had their own office
your potential market would be two
hundred thousand or if they each had
paid for their own seat in the software
there'd be two hundred thousand seats if
you did sell by dentist so you can start
to make some approximation here about
those dentists well there are only 187
000 dental offices in the u.s according
to you know some market research we saw
online so
some office might have multiple dentists
in them so you're seeing how i'm making
a much more interesting
approximation of what my total
addressable market is by working from
the bottom up and that is
so much more credible when you go into a
vc it means you understand your
customers in market in a deep way not a
superficial way instead of being lazy
you're being thoughtful with investors
thoughtful people who are of action are
so much more attractive oh you get stuff
done you take action
and in fact doing a bottom-up tam puts
you in the bucket of taking action you
didn't just take the easy way out and
grab a number
when i see that i just think this
person's lazy they just spent the least
amount of time on the slide or thinking
about their market
now let's say you capture 10 of the
market of the number of dentists dental
offices out there well a thousand
dollars a month times 18 000 or so
dental offices
you know 224 million dollars a year in
revenue right it's pretty great you're
making a real business that's a great
business that i mean just thinking about
it right now somebody build you know
software for dental offices or tell me
you know what's the state of the art
there seems like a pretty viable market
getting 10 of it equals 200 million a
year pretty great market so doing a
bottom-up tab is just going to make you
so much more credible